I'm birth control member of parliament
still member of parliament but I was 20
nearly 20 years in government of Austria
his minister for economic affairs
foreign minister and seven years chance
of Austrian Prime Minister and I think
innovation is a core instrument for
modernizing our economies and the whole
region one very important element could
be the newly designs strategy of the
European Union the Commission and the
council of member states for the whole
venue region this is a region consisting
of more than hundred billion people
one-fifth of the European Union and
there is money available more than 100
billion euro for the next period
financial period will be available if we
have more than 50 universities located
along the river of Daniel and this could
expand of course to Central Asia to the
Black Sea etc so I think this is one of
the most exciting things I've ever seen
during the last months to come it I hope
it will work